Hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week on
Teen Wolf was like the intervention episodes
of How I Met Your Mother, except it was How
I Met Your Beta starring Liam.
We got a nice resolution in the Scott Liam
story or at least a big wolf step forward.
But I think the real surprise was Funny Derek.
Who knew Tyler Hoechlin was allowed to be
so funny?
Hello any new people, if you're just finding
me for the first time I do weekly Teen Wolf
videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'm even doing a special comic con giveaway
that I'll explain after my episode review.
I'm going to start with my top 5 wtf moments
and then my review.
Careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet.
I'll wait just a sec...Okay, here we go.
Number 5 - Batman Derek and Sheriff Stalinski
Derek has been so much more fun this season
since getting his mojo stolen by Kate.
It's like he's got this whole new personality
that allows him to be funny.
Batman Derek was funny in a meta way, just
because it made you think of Sheriff Stalinski
like Gordon.
Their moments together ended up being every
bit as funny as the more traditional funny
scenes like with Malia and Stiles or Kira
falling down stairs in slow motion.
I didn't know Tyler Hoechlin was allowed to
be so funny as Derek, like when he and Chris
Argent were chained up in the police station.
Or when he was laying the sass on Peter about
Mute's not being able to talk.
Normally someone like Hoechlin would be the
lead of a show, like it would be written from
his perspective, not Tyler Poseys.
It is an ensemble cast, but Derek is a supporting
character.
So in exchange for all the awful things the
writers do to him every year.
They give him all the most gratuitous scenes.
Like he gets to be the Batman of the series.
He totally deserves it too, they've torn him
to pieces, taken away his alpha powers, killed
almost everyone he's ever loved and now they've
taken his true essence.
Add to that this season, Peter looks like
he's going to take advantage of his weakened
emotional state.
Number 4 - Peter's Old Habits Die Hard
Him killing the Mute was pure revenge for
the Axe to the chest.
Sheriff Stalinksi and Derek were going to
question him before Peter clawed his face
off.
I'm surprised Peter didn't take the opportunity
to throw Derek's joke about Mute's talking
back in his face, but it wasn't really a moment
for that kind of humor and his actual cool
guy walk away line was way better.
Last season Peter's secret goal was all about
learning the truth about Malia, now that he's
found her what could his secret plan be?
And how would he use Derek?
I think it has something to do with his true
essence that Kate stole.
I'm wondering if Peter's going to try and
use that to restore his Alpha powers.
If that's even possible.
Deucalion told them about absorbing your beta's
life force by killing him.
So maybe Peter is going to do something like
that.
He already killed Derek's sister Lucy to become
the Alpha once.
There's nothing stopping him from trying again
with Derek.
At least once Derek gets back what Kate took
from him.
Peter getting his Alpha powers back is also
a nice mirror for getting his money back.
Number 3 - Malia versus the Full Moon
She and Stiles are probably my favorite pair
on the show right now, they're a lot more
fun than Scott and Kira and they seem a lot
closer too.
I guess because what they've been through
in some way is more traumatic.
Maybe because they've both killed people and
been on the outside of the group for a big
chunk of last year.
Any scene they're in turns into some adorable
Malia doesn't understand moment and even when
it got super intense in the basement I never
thought the show would go super dark and make
her maul Stiles.
Her story as it relates to Peter is still
a huge question mark, I'm still waiting for
them to follow up on that.
Stiles is her anchor so I don't think she'd
ever leave him.
But I do wonder if Stiles would ever leave
the Pack to go with her.
If she ever did want to go away to get to
know Peter better.
If any of you watch Arrow, remember at the
end of season 2 how Thea chose to go with
Merlyn.
Number 2 - Lydia Decodes The Deadpool List
So just a quick heads up, during this scene
there was an issue with the broadcast where
the audio dropped out and you couldn't hear
Lydia and Mason talking.
It was in that record player room with the
freaky wall.
That wasn't a special effect or anything,
the audio messed up and MTV posted the clip
with the correct audio on the official teen
wolf website.
The Deadpool list is the whole impetus for
the killings this year.
Here's a shot of it.
Look at what certain people are worth.
It's implied that the more powerful people
are, the more you get paid for killing them.
Who is this person Carrie Hudson who's worth
twice as much as Scott, a true alpha?
Does it not completely suck that Kira is only
worth 6 dollars, Derek is only worth 15 and
Lydia 20.
Malia's not on the list we saw, but I think
that they just showed us part of the list,
I think the full one is longer.
It's like Scott's Pack collectively is barely
worth one of the normal supers on the list
put together.
Some of the names are unfamiliar.
So presumably we'll meet them in the next
several episodes.
The Benefactor, as we learned from Werewolf
Beer Delivery Man, is paying out mercenaries
to kill supers.
Side note too, we also learned during that
reveal that Liam's friends were mercenaries.
He's not on the list just like Malia, but
that doesn't mean he won't end up on it before
the end of the season.
and my Number 1 WTF Moment - Scott Gives Liam
an Intervention
More than anything the WTF moments in this
episode were funny moments, and the rapid
way this deteriorated from the bite, to the
bath tub to the lake house was just hilarious.
It reminded me of the How I Met Your Mother
Intervention episodes.
Liam, you have a problem.
In case you missed it, Scott was basically
quoting Derek the whole episode.
"Liam, We're Brothers now."
The Bite is a gift.
Even Chris Argent had to tell Scott to just
do his own thing.
Like he had completely spaced on the fact
Derek is a terrible people person.
So he was just replicating his own terrible
experience becoming a werewolf.
Liam is still a big question mark right now
in terms of character development.
Scott and Derek came to blows before turning
into BFFs in season 3, so I wouldn't be surprised
if Liam went a little nuts on him before the
end of the season.
There still the unanswered question of why
Liam smashed up that Teacher's car at his
last school, he said that's what he did to
get kicked out.
But he didn't explain why he did it.
When he smashed it up he wrote "It's your
fault" on the car, and we have no idea what
that means.
Liam has currently dethroned Derek as the
angriest character on the show.
Somebody give him a giant wolf size chill
pill.
But now it's your turn, let me know what your
favorite moment was and do you think Liam
is going to chill and be a good beta to Scott,
or is it going to blow up in their faces?
Don't forget, this is only the first half
of the season.
At Comic Con next week, they're going to air
the trailer for 4b, the second batch of episodes
that will air next year.
That will be a whole different plot.
But overall this episode was again, my new
favorite.
I gave it an A just because I'm super impressed
anytime a show can continue to build the energy
of a story consistently for this many episodes.
Usually what you'd see would be some one off
episode to stop the action dead in it's tracks,
but I like that Teen Wolf has chosen to go
more serialized.
It's something that Game of Thrones does too.
The story each week builds on what happened
last week, it's not like a bunch of one-off
stories that don't connect or anything.
I love what they're doing with Derek by making
him like the supernatural Batman of the season,
helping Sheriff Stalinski solve the deadpool
murders.
We're still learning about the Benefactor,
and because of the way they're teasing Liam's
friends as mercenaries and Batman Derek hitting
the problem from different angles, I think
all of the characters will learn who it is
at the same time.
I'm also wondering how Parrish fits into all
this, I love how they're kind of pairing him
with Lydia so far.
She did make that comment that she's over
dating High School boys, so either that means
she's going to hook up with Parrish or she's
just going to spend a lot of time with him
solving murders.
That just reminds me of the X-Files, but Parrish
isn't really a match for Mulder yet.
Lydia I could buy as Sculley.
So big hanging questions after the episode
are, who is the Benefactor and who is that
person that's worth twice as much as everyone
else.
Carrie Hudson.
Here's the details on my Comic Con giveaway.
I'm going to do my episode 5 review and that
will be the last Teen Wolf video before Comic
Con actually starts.
When I post that, it will be the start of
my Teen Wolf giveaway.
I'm just going to pick one random subscriber
from the comments to get a Teen Wolf Lacrosse
Shirt.
The giveaway will be open until I post my
Episode 6 review the week after comic con.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment when I post
that video.
And a quick note about what's happening at
Comic Con, I will be watching the Teen Wolf
panel, if you want me to upload it or highlights
from it, be sure to vote on my poll.
I have a link in the description.
I'm asking everyone which panels they want
me to do videos for the most so I can prioritize
which order I do them.
In the meantime, click here for my episode
3 video and click here for my episode 2 video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!